despite the fast start to his NFL career
our next guest is considered quiet and
reserved not much is known about his
personality although there are rumors he
knows ninja and Drake and considers
himself an above-average dancer at the
urging of his representatives he's
recently joined social media and
apparently has a few followers in two
seasons he has 14 touchdowns you'd think
that in that time he'd be having more
memorable celebrations but still young
still talented please welcome to Jude
Smith
okay good love the pants okay mode
looking clean joining us on behalf of
Gatorade zero so how many followers do
you have
social media I'll be talking about
Instagram Twitter you tell me ah let's
include Instagram Twitter snapchat
YouTube I would say I have around like 4
mil 4 million altogether okay yeah
Instagram is 2.3 and and what's the
number one question you get um number
one question I always get is can you
dance with me so no matter where you are
somebody to say can you dance with me
yeah because of the celebrations and
everything I do the whole dancing is
everyone's all about dancing but you'd
like to get the other little kids
they're all want to do the the dancing I
do the celebrations like how'd you do
that how do you come over to
celebrations or they're pretty much two
main questions wait okay do you practice
these dances yes I do and in like a
mirror uh
to go out and party a little bit oh you
do okay so you go to the clubs and they
know dance right yeah I'm only 22 years
old
this is Judge Freeh's own ring right
here I was curious about that where you
go okay how about this who's your idol
when it comes to celebrations like you
never saw somebody on TV and go like
Deion Sanders or I mean Dion could could
bring it yeah Dion can bring it you know
oh it's gonna bring out but for me more
so like we couldn't celebrate in hi in
college and then we got to NFL it was
just the first year you know obviously
is my first year and you know they
allowed it and I was like man I'm taking
this to a whole nother level
I'm trying it much guys it's possible to
get involved and that's basically what
we're trying to do is though it's been
fun these past three years
how important is fortnight to your life
oh it's pretty important if I said
there's a beautiful girl that wants to
go out to dinner or you can stay home
and do fortnight versus Drake or ninja
let's say ninja says hey
let's do four tonight hit me up or I got
somebody spectacular waiting for dinner
and gain out both I'm a ton ninja I'm
going to be there because I was actually
open all night to like 2:00 a.m.
really yeah have you ever been injured
doing fortnight no like no hand wrist
none of that thumb none of that stuff
nope guys get hurt
guys do get hurt but how the partnership
that the hyper action is massaged to the
house me uh you know what hurts after a
game out there not Yammer
but you won multiple times and how ok
let's say winning a regular season game
against like the Browns or winning
fortnight more excited you're with
Gatorade so explain let me hear the
pitch let me see how well you do with
pitching Gator head here
well gator is a new product obviously
Gator has been throughout my whole
career it's someone perform at my best
ability
I'm obviously Gatorade zero Gatorade is
a legendary brand and I'd like to be
part of this is what this is why I'm
here as you guys know Gator is zero has
all the electrolytes I need no sugars at
it that thing that'll be my offseason
workout so and 20% off if you use Gator
a SB code there you go alright by the
way do you like you come back down from
freaking out after meeting LeBron yeah
that was I like that that's big that's a
big did you get a picture I did get a
picture okay cuz that's a big bad
picture uh you know we chopped it up he
talked and then also following me on
Instagram
how do you how do you think he would
have known as a football player I think
it would be great you know obsolete
desires and ability obviously he's
probably one of the most physical dudes
in NBA so it would have transferred what
about Shaq
oh for sure to dominate it like we look
at Aaron Donald is a big guy
yeah or Donna consumed I mean jack is
Jack is nothing's going down the middle
and he's blocking everything all right
everybody's done this all the greats
have done it Russell Wilson just did it
your draft profile out of USC is right
there we took out all the positives by
the way
juju Smith Schuester joining us behalf
of Gatorade zero and he's incorporated
that into his offseason routine so those
were the things said about you when you
came out of USC read some of your
favorites there o your least favorites
there this one says juju is missing some
of the speed traits teams once for the
number one receiver hmm okay well let
you talk about speed okay explain it but
that's what they said so they basic
called you slow yeah he called me slow
ok so what's another one I'm really sure
the second gear to run under the Depot
they should call me slow ok see needs to
get better I freeing himself at the
breakpoint of his routes so basically
saying that I can't you know break away
from your slow so how's the maintain
focus I don't know what that means
that's better than you know being slow
yeah we're pretty much all saying that
I'm pretty much left so your name should
be juju Smith slow slow sir
instead of Shuster here slow slow I'm
putting slow in there do you care who
wins on Sunday yes you do I do you hate
the Patriots I hate the Patriots but you
know I want the RAM suing because Ellis
I'm an LA native okay and no you also
beat the Patriots do you want to play
for the Rams one day no I mean obviously
I love my franchise I know just throwing
it out there you know
okay I'm pretty sure my family will love
to me you probably love for me to come
home but oh man Pittsburgh other way no
oh
do your best to bring Antonio Brown back
to Pittsburgh here do my best
yeah a B if you wanna know I don't know
- camera because this is a message -
okay a B is watching so do your best
you know - a B no go right here on the
microphone oh okay okay
this camera yeah though for the camera
find you okay here we go
a B obviously you're watching this you
know you're still there our heart you
believe black and go man let's win a
Super Bowl get back to business
business is booming there you go would
you check the internet to see if Antonio
Brown says he's now coming back to
Pittsburgh it should be that should be
breaking news there it's great to meet
you Congrats great success so far and I
hope you get a little faster okay
[Music]
Shuster four more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]